reçoit aujourd'hui une importante
distinction la médaille de l'UQAM pour
souligner ses grandes réalisations tant
au Québec au Canada durant ces 40 années
de carrière il est avec nous bonsoir
monsieur Fortin bonsoir alors c'est tout
un honneur qui vous est fait aujourd'hui
mérité d'ailleurs
40 ans de carrière de quoi est-ce que
vous êtes le plus fiable c'est vraiment
très très émouvant comme comme
circonstances comme cérémonie parce que
quand ça vient de chez nous c'est
toujours plus émouvant comme tel alors
que quand ça vient de l'extérieur ben
alors c'est plus formel donc ce sont vos
pairs à quelque part qui vous
reconnaissent les gens avec qui vous
avez travaillé pendant plusieurs années
et la reconnaissance je pense ce que de
spécial que j'ai fait je crois ce qui
était reconnu comme tel c'est que j'ai
pas seulement
disons enseigné 10 000 étudiants dont de
très très bons comme ce fibrochu Éric
Gérard ou d'autres mais également j'ai
fait une carrière universitaire en
recherche toutes sortes de sujets mais
troisièmement et c'est ça qui est plus
rare j'ai beaucoup travaillé en
diffusion
des résultats scientifiques parce que
Albert Einstein nous a toujours dit
ce qui est dans la science mal diffusée
mal connue au parle plus grand nombre ça
sert absolument rien donc ça sert à rien
de faire la recherche si notre monde
c'est pas de quoi il s'agit puis en tire
pas des conséquences on a vu aujourd'hui
des données de l'Institut de la
statistique du Québec sur les quarts
entre la rémunération des hommes et des
femmes le salaire horaire moyen qui est
encore 91% celui des hommes la
rémunération hebdomadaire qui est autour
de 82% pourquoi est-ce qu'encore un
écart comme ça on vient d'un monde qui
est très différent d'une autre autrefois
où les femmes restaient à la maison puis
parfois il y en avait qu'on appelle les
fanes de carrière qui prenaient un
emploi mais en général était pas mariée
etc et donc aujourd'hui avec le niveau
d'éducation des femmes qui est en
ascension absolument
fulgurante d'un côté et de l'autre ce
que
les services de garde éducatif pour les
tout-petits enfants vous pouvez aller en
service de garde dès que vous sortez de
votre congé parental mais là ça aide
beaucoup les femmes à voir des carrières
qui sont en continuité plutôt que de
passer d'une jobine à l'autre comme
c'était beaucoup le cas autrefois après
une naissance et donc au Québec ont un
particulièrement avantagé par ces
phénomènes là au niveau d'éducation des
femmes et services de garde qui ont
l'espère vont finir par rencontrer la
demande qui dépasse évidemment l'offre à
l'heure actuelle et donc avec tout ça le
rapport entre le salaire des femmes et
le salaire des hommes
ont continuellement augmenté mais il
n'est pas encore il n'est pas encore au
sommet
écoutez moi j'ai eu cinq enfants des
enfants ça demande du temps on les adore
on les aime notamment pour eux et
absolument conditionnel mais ça demande
du temps et donc dans un couple
habituellement il faut qu'on ait au
moins un des deux puissent être
littéralement sur appel quand c'est
quelque chose à gérer quelque chose qui
va pas à la maison j'aimerais vous
entendre sur l'immigration vous avez
produit des rapports sur ce sujet le
fameux seuil acceptable pour que les
nouveaux arrivants soient bien intégrés
quel est-il selon vous c'est entre trop
puis passé 100
000 immigrants par année comme le
gouvernement fédéral
sans vouloir pousser le Québec à faire à
l'heure actuelle c'est complètement
c'est très dangereux à l'heure actuelle
c'est très risqué la Suède qui est un
pays ouvert
c'est un goût vert et progressiste ils
sont passés de 50000 immigrants par
année à 120 000 en 2014-2016 et là la
réaction
contre ce flux considérable d'immigrants
en Suède de la population native
suédoise était tellement négatif que ça
a fait monter les parties fascistes et
littéralement nazi ayant gagné Lyon ils
ont gagné l'élection littéralement mais
quelle est la capacité économique du
Québec d'accueillir des immigrants moi
j'ai fait des calculs avec la méthode
mise au point par le Conseil du patronat
et eux sont arrivés un chiffre de 80 000
mais quand on corrige les erreurs qui
ont fait dans leur calcul parce qu'ils
ont fait des erreurs importantes dans
leur calcul et qu'on a juste ça de
manière raisonnable avec les derniers
chiffres publiés par l'emploi puis par
l'Institut la statistique ça donne à peu
près moi ça m'a donné 53
donc c'est pas très loin de ce que les
le gouvernement actuel de la quête vise
j'ai pas c'est pas parce que je veux
appuyer la cape comme tel mais c'est
justement pour vous indiquer que même
quand on fait des calculs techniques la
réponse se trouve dans le juste milieu
vous suivez aussi la croissance
économique comment entre voyez-vous 2023
au Québec
mais là la Banque du Canada a décidé de
de d'augmenter les taux d'intérêt alors
commencer à les augmenter et même nous
dit c'est pas fini attendez-vous qu'il y
en ait d'autres augmentations taux
d'intérêt donc
c'est presque certain leur coûter là je
suis pas devin c'est presque certain que
le ralentissement économique qui est
commencé va se poursuivre sa confondir
au moins un peu dans le début de l'année
qui vient ou dans le premier semestre
qui va venir on sait pas quel va être la
taille de ça ça va dépendre aussi
beaucoup de de comment la banque
centrale réagit dans ces taux d'intérêt
mais il y a quand même de l'espoir
l'espoir c'est que quand on regarde le
taux d'inflation dans les trois derniers
mois pas depuis un an quand comme les
médias en général nous donne comme
résultat
la distance entre il y a 6 mois il y a
un an là c'est passé quand on regarde
les trois derniers mois ça baisse
l'inflation
l'impact sur les prix de l'énergie avec
la garde l'Ukraine c'est plafonné bon
peut-être qu'on va avoir une autre
légère augmentation mais aussi les les
transports des marchandises par exemple
en Shanghai los Angel ou en Rotterdam et
à New York ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
maintenant donc l'impact sur les prix
des biens et moins fort donc on espère
qu'avec tout ça ça va continuer à
baisser les salaires même les salaires
mènent pas l'inflation au contraire
malheureusement les travailleurs ils ont
pris du retard sur l'inflation oui on
pourrait se parler très très longtemps
j'ai l'impression que ce serait encore
très intéressant 1h30 merci beaucoup
monsieur Fortin et félicitations
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI